okay so I'm gonna talk to you today
about a competition that I hope to run
in 2016 we were emulating in some sense
the machine learning crowd that does a
ton of you know
competitions like the famous Cavill
competitions within causal inference and
I'll let you know a little bit you know
in the 20 minutes about how that went
what our results were and you know what
we learned from doing that seriously
okay okay okay how do I go back
all right yeah seriously badass hurry
points going down by the second okay
causal inference is hard I know that
sounds whiny that's okay I'm kind of
used to it
why is causal inference hard because
unlike so many fields like an you know
machine learning often you can have
training data test data you know how
well you're doing by comparing how you
do once you've built a model on your
training data by applying it to the test
data nothing like that exists in causal
inference right we have missing
counterfactuals what we don't know is
the world that we didn't see so unless
you are able to jump between alternate
universes or go back in time it's really
hard to figure out what the truth was so
we had to make all kinds of adjustments
because of that in the design but in
general and causal inference you've got
two main sets of choices one is run a
randomized experiment that's the gold
standard that's what you're supposed to
do but there are lots of situations
where ethically logistically etc you
can't do that I don't need to do it
because I've got a can you hear me okay
so we're gonna Mize experiments great
often can't do them so then what do we
do observational studies so that's
that's the bulk of what people do and
what that literature is about because
yes there's some statistical literature
about randomized experiments but it's
just an easier task right so when we're
in the world of observational studies we
don't have a randomized experiment the
whole name of the game is accounting for
your covariance okay so what does it
mean to account for your covariance well
the biggest problem there is you
probably haven't measured them all right
so being able to say that I've measured
all confounders everything that predicts
both my treatment and my outcome it's
pretty hard to ever say that that
happened right so we punted on that that
is not part of this competition you know
that's that's something and then it's
not a lot of part of the literature
frankly and I'm half
to talk to you about have done some work
in that area but that's that's not about
today so instead what we focused on is
the second part was usually what people
do is say let's just control for
everything we can let's measure as much
as we can let's control for as much as
we can that's great
but once you do that it gets harder and
harder to build models that you actually
believe okay okay so sorry the
competition because of that focus on
this part of it the parametric
assumptions okay so how do we build a
model this is for anyone you see me give
a talk you seen the slide so I apologize
but most of this crowd is is somewhat
natively so hopefully I won't be boring
you too much here's causal inference in
one slide I've got a bunch of
observations that received a treatment
in red I've got a bunch of observations
that did not receive the treatment in
blue the I've got one confounder in this
case so I've got set up a really simple
situation where there's only one thing
that predicts whether or not I got the
treatment and it also predicts the
outcome okay so that's great and that's
your pretest score and it's on the
x-axis so what are the solid lines are
the true relationship between that
confounder and my outcome which is a
post-test the whole you know don't use
regression to do causal inference
correlation is not causation it's a
little misleading because actually if
you can get that model right you can do
causal inference right
you actually if you know you've got one
confounder you can fit the right model
game on you're doing well
the problem is usually more the first
part we don't know we have all the
confounders and then the second part it
can be hard to model so what's the hard
to model piece of it well that's the
fact that here we've got something
that's not going to be fit well saved
with a linear regression this is this is
why we should be beating up on
regression for causal inference right
because it's just not the right model a
lot of the time so here the true
response surfaces as you see are curve
you fit something linear to that it's
not gonna do well in particular it's not
going to do well here because I don't
have overlap perfect overlap between the
two groups right so you notice the
controls are hanging out down here with
low pretest scores the treated or up
here with higher pretest scores so then
the model just wants to extrapolate into
that area of the covariant space where I
don't have a lot of information so
another way of thinking about that is
that for these controls I don't really
have people who look like them I don't
have empirical counterfactuals I've got
no one over here saying what would have
happened to me if I'd gotten the
treatment and the same for the treated
over on the right hand side I don't have
controls who look like them who can give
me information about what would have
happened had I not gotten the treatment
and that's the whole name of the game we
need evidence on both sides we need to
be able to think for each person about
that alternate universe right so we're
missing the alternate universe here okay
so there's two pieces here there's this
overlap piece and then there's this
fitting curves is hard now fitting
curves isn't that hard in one dimension
but what about 20 40 50 200 mm
dimensions or it gets harder then again
we have all these tools now for flexible
inference that didn't exist or couldn't
really be implemented well 20 years ago
and say propensity scores were being
developed now we've got them so if
you've heard about propensity scores
that's it's all about this it doesn't
solve your I haven't measured all the
confounders problem great tool and a lot
of ways in particularly because it lets
you see where you don't have overlap but
it's only solving this problem it's not
solving the hard problem okay
likewise all the other methods I'll be
talking about today are in that same
realm okay so there's been an explosion
of methods the vast majority of
literature in causal inference and
statistics in the past 20-30 years has
been about solving that problem believe
it or not so all those matching methods
weighting methods sub classification
that's all about that
more recently acting in the past 10
years there have been more semi and
nonparametric methods and moving on to
kind of combinations of all of these
things and ensemble methods say like the
super learner which I'll talk about a
little later okay so before I get there
again the competition part of what we
were thinking about was okay there's a
whole literature there's a million
methods out there there's a whole
literature why is it so hard to figure
out what to use or how does the typical
researcher decide okay from my problem
what usually you know what it's about
your field and the journal you'd like to
submit to and what they want to see
which is a pretty crappy way of deciding
right so what about science how should
we be thinking about how methods get
developed and how we evaluate them
fairly so we wanted to create a level
testing ground so this is what we saw in
the literature most papers only compare
a few methods methods where if there's
no difference between methods no one's
showing you that right because no
comparisons are Anathem up and there's a
bias towards shockingly given the
incentives in academia and beyond
there's a bias toward your own method
like I want to show simulations that
make my method look good right and if I
kind of inexpertly
you know implement the competition
method oh well it's not my method how
was I to know that I didn't choose the
tuning parameters correctly or I really
didn't do it justice and I'm not saying
anyone's being Machiavellian some people
maybe even recommend most people are not
being Machiavellian about it but there's
the incentives to do it right and to be
really fair and to actually move towards
the truth are not really there oh
there's a typo choice and you also might
only choose evaluation methods that
metrics that favor your method right
again are you thinking it's through that
way or you being doing that explicitly
or not it's it doesn't all miss matter
and then calibration to real life so
because of this challenge I said before
but you know there's no real data set
where we know the truth there are some
things constructed observational studies
that lean in that direction but in
general that that doesn't exist we often
are simulating how do we create
simulations that look like real life in
real data that's really hard to do and
I'm not saying we you know change the
world on that but we tried to stick in
that direction okay how did we do it we
crowdsource submissions right we have
and that's what a competition does send
me your best math that you implement it
you think this is a great method you
tell me how to implement it right or you
implement it yourself we had two
different versions we're reporting
everything and we're putting all the
data out there and all the code so that
anyone can go back and use it and try
out and see fair comparisons we really
tried to incorporate a number of metrics
that would evaluate the strengths and
weaknesses of different methods and we
started at least with covariant data
from a real study in an effort to try to
calibrate towards real life so the
covariant data is real and then we
simulated treatment and outcomes so that
we would be able to learn about you know
for this kind of the idea in our heads
was if we have this kind of assignment
mechanism maybe this kind of method as
well or if our response surface looks
like this maybe this kind of method it
turns out we did not learn that it was
hard okay so time line boring about 15
do it yourself
I'll talk about those differences in a
second submissions in about 15 black box
missions okay we assume ignore ability
throughout what does that mean it means
we assumed throughout that you had the
research you had all the covariance they
needed to do causal inference so we got
rid of that the hard problem ok there's
no confounding if you control for the
right set of covariance which is a
subset of the covariance we hand you
calibrate to real-life I just talked
about that we simulated treatment
assignments so we knew
the mechanisms were the goal is to
estimate the sample average trio that's
not right say it's set sample average
effect of the treatment on the treated
sorry that should say sacked I'm going
to talk about the simulation knobs in a
second and we had two versions do it
yourself in the black box here are the
simulation knobs degree of non-linearity
so I showed you a picture or something
nonlinear before now we've got
non-linearity and roughly you know
somewhere between 10 and 50 dimensional
space depending on the setup we did that
in any of a variety of different ways
step functions exponentiating things etc
etc percent of treated where sometimes
some methods don't do well when there
aren't more controls and treated so we
varied that it was either one-third
two-third or the opposite overlap
balance that's was another feature I
showed you in the plot before if you
don't have a lot of observations that
overlap with each other it gets harder
alignment that has to do with the fact
that maybe you have 50 covariance and
maybe 15 of them predict the treatment
and 20 of them predicts the response but
only 5 predict both in that case only 5
or confounders and methods vary a lot in
how good they are at figuring that out
and if you work really hard to for
instance if your propensity score
matching to balance all the things that
predict the treatment that's not
necessarily the best thing for your
treatment effect estimations you may be
ignoring important coverage for the
outcome and treatment effect
heterogeneity I think we had one setting
where everyone had the same treatment
effect and beyond that it was like the
picture where there's a lot of
heterogeneity ok then two different
competitions one with 7,700 datasets we
have 77 settings that varied levels of
that knob each setting had a hundred
different manifestations then people
sent us methods
that had to take a certain kind of input
and output something very specific and
boom we went to town with that the other
version was we handed out 20 datasets
for people who really believe this is an
art form I need to do it myself I need
to be intimate with the data and
thinking about it etc we gave 2 out 20
datasets to do that so I'm gonna focus
less on that part of the competition
because it's harder to make any strong
conclusions with 20 datasets okay so
here's a brief summary of the winners we
we did give out gold medals they were
gold covered plastic medals really but
but people I think felt good about the
medals that they got so but in some
times we didn't really feel comfortable
at the end of the day saying that there
were you know real winners because they
all kind of some things that were good
at this weren't good at that etc but
overall if you really pushed us the
winners were ones that flexibly modelled
the response surface right which is new
this has not been emphasized in causal
inference in the past thirty years
everything has been about modeling the
treatment assignment things like the
propensity score in part because again
there weren't these fancy methods until
recently that could do the other part
well so ones that really focused on the
expectation of the outcome conditional
on treatment and the covariance were the
ones that kicked ass at the end of the
day and those could have used a variety
of things to do that that flexible model
fitting from Bart random forests
Gaussian processes and often ensembles
thereof okay because at the end of the
day we were having a hard time learning
about what actually is the feature that
makes a difference and we couldn't
really learn that from our evaluation we
it was very noisy it was really hard to
find settings where one method really
dominated over the others we instead
created a bunch of new methods so it was
like you know I think there was a toys
heaven I was little like transformers
you could like take the one piece of
this and shove it into that right you
could like make cool hybrids so it was
it was a fun experiment like that let's
take this and shove it over here and so
I'll show you a little about those as
well
and we learned the most from that
process and it also made me think isn't
that a better way to do science where
instead of me saying for instance like I
I've written about Bart so Bart has to
win it's like well what if I take the
piece of Bart that's good and take the
cool thing about super learning that's
good and mash them together okay so here
are the people who won metals the first
it's called count cause it's an ensemble
algorithm that uses cross-validation to
choose between random forests and
Gaussian processes I will say though
that it shows random forests ninety-five
percent of the time I'm working on
Gaussian processes and causal imprints
right now and it's has a lot of promise
but it's hard to do well automatically
Bart is Bayesian additive regression
trees the mean function of Bart is a sum
of week learning regression trees and it
avoids overfitting by default prior
distributions kind of like a Bayesian
form of boosted regression trees super
learner plus T mla's this is like the
mark vanderlin camp for people who know
that world so they had a big in
somnolent ensemble that had a wide latch
Lee it wasn't that wide a library of
different options both to fit the
response surface and the assignment
mechanism and then it applied a target
maximum likelihood estimation adjustment
at the end h2o by the way all these
things these are all sitting in our and
I'm gonna give you links later or names
of packages this is another ensemble a
ensembles you know not some prizing Lee
ensembles get to choose the best along
or a variety of methods so the ensembles
did really well except for on
computational time right so it also
chose from among a variety of options
oh wow I'm running out of time I will
say that in the do-it-yourself
competition there was one real standout
submission by jr. Lockwood which I don't
have time to talk about this is also all
in the paper that I'll give you is it
sitting on archives
okay bunch of different things we looked
at so I'm gonna actually skip I'm sorry
the do it yourself because it's 20 data
sets and it's sitting in the paper so
it's all out there instead I'm gonna
show you the 7,700 data sets so all the
dark points so we've got sorry bias our
circles and our MSC and and and
left-hand access our MSC triangles and
right hand axis but in some sense and
the the everything has been standardized
by the standard deviation of the
outcomes if you're used to thinking like
effect size standardization it's it's
like that
so one takeaway is that everything did
decently well or most things did
decently well if you think of like 0.05
as being kind of a reasonably small
level of bias the mashups do better
because what you know we took a bunch of
the good features and put them together
for the most part here are the winners
and then there are a bunch of other
methods that did fine just not
superlative okay so we actually didn't
learn a lot from that piece we learn
more from this and I apologize for this
because there's no way I'm just gonna
have to tell you what all these letters
mean but this is interval length versus
coverage so basically we want things
that cover so we want things over here
where you see there's nothing and we
want things up here because we want
short intervals so short intervals that
cover is the name of the game and we
don't have a lot of that so Bart did
really well with regard to our amazeen
bias but not with coverage with coverage
it's getting like 83 percent 82 percent
it's got a really short interval that's
although when you switch it to have
symmetric intervals which makes no sense
from a Bayesian point of view it does
much better so we're still investigating
that
when you add the propensity score as a
covariant it does much better when you
combine it with TM le it does great
right super learner similarly see that
one over there didn't do so great
coverage wise for the in the beginning
when they added Burt boom it did much
better actually that that was the super
learner team who went back and thought
well let's throw Bart in the library and
they did and they resubmitted so we're
still learning about the coverage but
that was interesting
I have zero time and dinner rather lunch
is waiting so I'm gonna skip this piece
and just go to lessons learned all right
so the big the big takeaways for us were
that nonlinear response service is not
the model for the treatment but the
model for the response was really where
the action was which frankly fits with a
lot of theory Barton random forests they
generally liked read algorithms were the
ones that stood out as standalone as in
non ensemble algorithms coverage was a
problem across the board so we need to
think about that
Tim Ellie I have to say I was pretty
cynical about it before the competition
and now I'm kind of sold I still don't
really understand it because it's super
hard but I'm working more towards doing
that and and have built packages now
that include it by default because it's
so helpful and I will yes there's a new
competition this year which the deadline
is April 30th and it's a little tricky
so but if you goo well there there's the
link but also if you just Google a CIC
which stands for Atlanta causal
inference conference 2018 you will and
challenge you'll get there so I want to
thank you for for attending to this when
you can smell the pizza in the
background and I'll just leave this to
show you the packages that are sitting
on crayon to highlight a new Bart causal
one that we're about to put on crash
I know I said the same thing a month ago
but that incorporates a lot of the
features a lot of the good things we've
learned from this are now sitting in
there but it's ending on github if you
want to help us test it out the
competition beta is sitting on github so
if you're writing a causal inference
paper and you need testing grounds boom
you've got seventy seven hundred
datasets across a wide variety of
settings use them and then cite us of
course and the paper is a second round
of reviews that steps i but is sitting
on archive so we'd love comments on it
so thank you very much
[Applause]
you